♪ I saw a story about a girl ♪
♪ Not even 20 yet ♪
♪ She was bullied
by some trolls ♪
♪ Just for being different ♪
♪ And as I read,
I wondered how much further ♪
♪ We'd be along ♪
♪ If all society's bullies ♪
♪ Just disappeared
and were gone ♪
♪ It's not okay to say
that someone ♪
♪ Is different from us all ♪
♪ Assuming we are right
and big ♪
♪ And that they are wrong
and small ♪
♪ There's no excuse
to make this poor girl feel ♪
♪ She's off the plan ♪
♪ Even if she self-identifies
as a... ♪
Wolf?
♪ Are you fucking kidding me,
a goddamn wolf? ♪
♪ That's who the stupid kid
thinks she is? ♪
♪ Thank God I kept on reading ♪
♪ Can't believe
I almost re-tweeted this ♪
♪ You're not a martyr
or a victim ♪
♪ Just an attention whore ♪
♪ Making a mockery of legit ♪
♪ Social movements from before ♪
♪ You're literally crying wolf
while kids out there ♪
♪ Are getting disowned
for being gay ♪
♪ So don't claim discrimination
'cause you know damn well ♪
♪ It's not the same, in fact,
I take back what I said ♪
♪ Who knows where
we would be today ♪
♪ Or what other crap ♪
♪ These coddled kids
would come up with ♪
♪ If the bullies go away ♪
♪ If the bullies
go away ♪
♪ If the bullies go away ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Life is an ecosystem,
at least that's what they say ♪
♪ You got to think
about what happens ♪
♪ When you take one piece away ♪
♪ And when we cracked down
on the bullies ♪
♪ Perhaps we just went too far ♪
♪ 'Cause with nothin'
but encouragement ♪
♪ These kids
don't even know what they are ♪
♪ One thinks
that she's a vampire ♪
♪ This one thinks
that he's a wolf ♪
♪ This one's got a pony toy ♪
♪ And jerkin' off
onto its hooves ♪
♪ This one bought a pillow
printed with an anime cartoon ♪
♪ He's bringing it
to family functions ♪
♪ Saying that it's his waifu ♪
♪ This one self-identifies
as the planet Mercury ♪
♪ She's a genderfluid otherkin
who's proud that she's obese ♪
♪ Reality's a trigger word,
so we're quickly losing touch ♪
♪ We need some kids
to have the balls to say ♪
♪ You all are fucking nuts!
♪ Look, you're not an animal ♪
♪ No matter
how you fucking feel ♪
♪ Vampires and werewolves
are not even fucking real ♪
♪ Bullies, you need
to right the ship ♪
♪ Put us back on proper course,
you need to come back ♪
♪ And restore some balance
to the Force ♪
♪ That's a Star Wars quote
I used ♪
♪ Please make fun of me
for that ♪
♪ Say my songs are never funny ♪
♪ And I'm looking old and fat ♪
♪ You've still got it all
within you ♪
♪ You just have to believe ♪
♪ So dust yourself off,
get on out there ♪
♪ And go give some kids
swirlies ♪
♪ Shove 'em in the lockers,
give 'em wedgies ♪
♪ You do what you do,
haters gonna hate ♪
♪ And for that,
we depend on you ♪
♪ Our skin is getting thinner
each and every single day ♪
♪ And there'll be nobody left
to guide us back if all ♪
♪ The bullies go away ♪
♪ Life's an ecosystem ♪
That's right, bullies.
♪ At least that's what ♪
-♪ They say ♪ -Never stop
believing in yourself.
♪ You got to think about ♪
-♪ What happens when ♪
-Don't let anybody
-♪ You take one piece away ♪
-try to change who you are.
-♪ If the bullies go away ♪
-You are necessary.
♪ If the bullies ♪
-♪ Go away ♪
-You matter.
-♪ If the bullies go away ♪
-So the next time
somebody tries to tell you
not to make fun of someone
who's being a total weirdo,
-♪ If the bullies go away ♪
-just think of this song.
(fading):
♪ Go away, go away, go away... ♪